47 عصرا جديدا نضفتها اليونسكو الى قائمه
التراث الثقافي غير المجد القائمه الجديده
ضمت العديد من المكونات الثقافيه العربيه
والتي تنتمي الى معارف وفنون ومهارات
تقليديه عربيه تعمل المنظمات الامميه على
اصونها جاء البن الخلاني السعودي والخنجر
العماني والمنسف الاردني والهريسه
التونسيه وصناعه الاعواد السوريه وغناء
الراي الجزائري الشعبي على راس قائمه
اليونسكو الجديده المزيد مع الكلاب
الثقافيه غير الماديه وهي في الغناء الراي
الجزائري كفانا الاصيل يخص الجزائر
في منطقه الخليج العربي خصوصا جزءا من
التراث غير المادي ومن مصر اخترت
الاحتفالات المتعلقه برحله العائله
المقدسه من بيت لحم الى مصر للقائمه
الجديده ومن الامارات صنف فان التطبيق
التل الاماراتي واحدا من التراث غير
المادي وسجل نخيل التمر العربي ايضا في
قائمه الامميه وكان فان صناعه العود
السوري احد ابرز اصناف قائمه اليونسكو
جديده كذلك المنسف الاردني كوليمه
احتفاليه شعبيه اردنيه واضيف للقائمه ايضا
الخنجر العماني المعروف باستخدامه كازيه
شعبيه في سلطنه عمان والهريسه التونسيه
المميزه وشهيره
[موسيقى]